I every job that I went to I use that as
an opportunity to learn everything about
this company even if it doesn't if my
job description doesn't say that because
what I want to do is make this company
more efficient and better because of
what what because of my involvement yeah
if you see a lot of people don't
understand how to get a raise and how to
work within the company system and the
reason for that is school right the way
that school teaches you is here's what's
on the syllabus
here's your tests here's extra credit
you do all these things this is the
points you will get mm-hmm in the
workplace that's not how it works is
you're creating a work soldier is what
you want right well and then you
shouldn't get well not not that you
shouldn't but like most people they go
all I've been a loyal you know employee
for 10 years I should get paid more
right like yes you should be rewarded
rewarded for your loyalty but then
there's there's a reason why some new
guy that comes in might get paid more
because that person is effective they're
adding value exactly and no one knows
how to add value that's what the that's
where the problem lies like I understood
very early on how to get into a
workplace for the bottom money like for
the cheapest amount as possible get my
foot in the door then I prove myself
within that company make up more money
and then I can argue a better price
point if I become irreplaceable to that
company I threatened to leave and then
they'll give me more money yeah they
need you you're an asset exactly or not
an employee anymore you're an actual
asset to the company a friend of ours
proved proved herself in a marketing
company recently and got herself a
six-figure income by doing that that's
[ __ ] crazy
yeah because she she when she went in as
like a like a data entry type of person
an intern and then she came back studied
the company did this presentation and
did all this work and boom she secured
herself as like a high position that's
amazing and
I think like that's what I mean by a
side hustle right like let's say you
don't ever do all these other things but
if you can not only prove your value but
bring money into the company now you
become irreplaceable and if you can't
and if they don't value you in that way
then that's a horrible company you leave
and you do that do you do the same thing
to a to a company that will recognize
that and you will get paid more I hope a
lot of people can take this to heart too
because it's I don't want people to and
this once again is coming from an
employer and I've dealt with this issue
with a lot of employees where they they
believe that time spent equals I deserve
more money to a certain extent that's
true to a certain extent yes so what
happens is they have this idea of well I
want to get paid more for doing the same
amount of work yeah you know and for as
an employer that wouldn't make sense to
me and there's been points to where
specifically I'm one of my businesses we
hired somebody else to manage the the
store instead of this person who has
been here longer yeah and in his mind he
was jaded he goes well how come I'm not
and he never said it but I could sense
it you know when I come in and I sense
the motivation is down or whatever and
partially you know we did talk about it
before but I had to talk to him again
about it was he like cuz I was here
longer how come this other person came
in and got it exactly and I gave him
that explanation I had explained to him
one more time because his his work
output was terrible yeah and at this
point now he's about to get fired so but
you know it's all about second chances
with me so you know I talked to him I'll
go straight up I said you are upset
because this person got a raise and they
took the position that you wanted and
you didn't get it he goes oh no no no
I'm not I was like listen you're not
gonna get in trouble I just wanted you
to be honest so I could fix this problem
he goes yeah I just felt a little weird
I said well let me put this in
perspective how I see it as an employer
is that you have been here longer than
her and she's been working twice as hard
as you and not only she'd be working
twice as hard she has actually
recommended things for this company that
has worked really well yeah you have you
came in here and you're very fun to be
around but you do the bare minimum work
yeah and at times even with the bare
minimum work you mess up but people
don't recognize that he doesn't want to
take he didn't want to take
responsibility for that
yeah and all he saw was time spent
equalled more money yeah but that's also
immaturity too yeah like like a lot of
the positions that we have are entry
level jobs for like college students and
stuff like that if you're still doing
this as an adult then you're completely
[ __ ] low IQ and eighty-eight it's it
was it is so weird because I guess for
him it was hard for me because he almost
wanted me to tend to his emotions but he
didn't want to listen to the facts that
were laid before him yeah so I can't sit
here and say well emotionally I should
have gave you the race it doesn't work
that way man you didn't add value yeah
this person did and this person did it
in literally half the time at you they
also don't see what you do cuz we see
things from top bottom but we also know
what it feels like to be an employee
yeah so that that's the burden right is
like this is the age-old conflict like
you have business owners and then you
have employees and employees always
think that business owners are a bunch
of greedy fat guys that are smoking
their cigars with the [ __ ] monopoly
hats and [ __ ] and in and in the
employees are these like guys are being
taken advantage of that's kind of like
the stereotype right but then what they
fail to remember is that employers have
been employees just know the struggle
know what it feels like but once we get
the whole picture we realize a lot of
the misconceptions that we had as
employees and and I think the biggest
problem though is the expectations are
not set up right for employees when they
graduate college and the work things
aren't common sense yeah that should be
common sense so like you know if you're
at a workplace for like ten years plus
they go well I've been here for so long
I should get at least paid for like
loyalty or whatever which is true but
you also have to look at things as like
in the bigger picture right like if
you're doing the same thing a robot can
do a robot can can um replace you
unfortunately but if you don't keep
sharpening your tools as a worker and
becoming better and
faster or like smarter if you keep doing
the same exact thing then there's really
no reason why people are gonna keep you
and that's just the unfortunate truth
yeah right like for example like you
could be the hardest-working pager in
the world but if a cell phone comes
around
no one's gonna watch you anymore yeah so
that's the thing is like you got to
transform and better yourself and all
that stuff and unfortunately man I don't
think that they teach that in school
because in school it's so outdated so a
lot of people graduate without
understanding what they need to provide
and I think most people want to but
that's the problems that we run into
with new employees straight out of
college a lot of guys they want to do
good they want to work hard they want to
contribute they just don't know how so
we're not seeing eye to eye mm-hmm and I
think that's one of the struggles of
like people graduating and waking up to
what the world is really like one of the
things that I like that our partners do
we own a machi business and it's doing
really well one of the things that our
partners that are there for the
day-to-day that that really impresses me
is that they actually do leadership
meetings yeah where they teach a lot of
the employees how to be leaders and how
to be managers instead of just a day
employee you